welcome to the dark forest checking your
pals were there for for us shameless
confession about our obsession will make
us laugh and smile so let's explore the
dark forest Kathy ladnun intro hi it's
Jackie Kashian welcome to the dark
forest you know the websites Jackie
Kashian calm dark forest calm the dark
forest calm family pet ancestry.com I
like a URL you guys this is the program
dork on dork dialogue my name is Jackie
Kashian at let's do the credits let's do
the credits Mike Rick Berg composed and
sang that song you just heard he will
sing his lyrics to the Mexican Hat dance
at the end of the program Patrick Brady
is going to fix this audio and Vilmos
does my website Jackie Kashian calm dork
force.com just has the episodes it has
the bonus and the episode you can also
listen to it on itunes and you can
review the show on iTunes and that's
what's there are comments available on
door for us calm right now which is a
wordpress document that is relatively
new so and i'm trying to do pictures on
there too so everything's on that
there's an app if you enjoy a specific
dork forest app but the bonus that was
going to be on the app is just on the it
side it's on the lips in page now and I
bring it over to the WordPress the dark
forest calm Jackie Kashian calm has
everything both dork forest and Jackie
Kashian have a donation button feel free
to donate folks knock yourselves out if
you enjoy the program I'd love to get a
hundred bucks a year from everybody if
you don't have a hundred dollars I get
that if you want to do ten dollars a
month I have not made that easy but if
you're listening to the show every month
you get to hear this feel free to donate
10 bucks a month for 10 months and then
november december we do something else
so but yeah just use the donation button
you can also use the amazon banner on
Jackie CARICOM which just brings you to
Amazon when you order from amazon the
dork forest gets a bit of a kick back
and that's a way to donate to the show
as well and help the show
on Jackie Kashian calm there's a bunch
of merch you can get a ranger of the
dark forest t-shirt you can get just the
dark forest t-shirt you can get my
stand-up albums which are circus people
it's never going to be bred and this
will make an excellent Horcrux you can
also get a Horcrux DVD and you can get a
spooky reading girl t-shirt which is a
stand-up joke that I do about reading
because i'm a dork so that is all
available on the website this week i am
on the road i'm just doing one night in
nevada city california opening for Maria
Bamford so if you are in the central
northern part of California which is a
very large state I'll be in nevada city
with Maria Bamford check my website or
hers Maria Bamford cow for that and the
next week I'm headlining outside of
Seattle in kirkland at laughs all right
enough I think that's it now what will
the heck how about all things comedy com
they're my umbrella group of podcasters
so if you're looking for more pods go to
all things comedy calm and check out one
of their they have a bunch of other
podcasts and I'm also doing another
podcast just about Stan of County with
Laurie Kilmartin over on the Nerdist
website so it's called the Jackie and
Laurie show I'll be the Jackie in that
but let's dork out already Dirk Dirk
Dirk let's do it hey it's Jackie Kashian
welcome to my living room in the dork
forest I'm with Kathy labman longtime
fan Cathy lineman Oh longtime fan of you
Jackie and I remember the first time I
saw you what good is a Minneapolis I
believe but i believe it was in some
handsome guys ain't it was in the st.
Paul the galtier Plaza yes possibly
that's kind of where my memory is I
remember you wearing you know what
you're wearing God God knows ahead shirt
Oh was I wearing that I still have that
plaid shirt it was a time when I just uh
I don't really get it you got to move to
Los Angeles and it's on the wind where
they're like hey uh that is super butch
no one will be surprised at all when
it's a and I I was just I thought it was
cute and no doubt it is i bought a tie a
couple about a month ago uh-huh a
gryffindor time when we were at the
harry potter well
and I put it on and I sent a picture to
my husband and he said seems a little
butch and i said it's a time it's gonna
be butch but it's a good you look super
cute though and I was like well you were
very supportive oh that's sweet and is
very so Kathy Lightman led a man with
Kathy with a see Kathy 11.com at Kathy
landman stand-up comic the last TV said
I saw of yours was that amazing Ferguson
said what which one I'm sorry Jude is
Ferguson yeah and talk about the the
weight loss thing yes I done it since
then but that whole one yeah but that
was the one that I did um in probably
two years as a 40 at august of two
thousand four yeah yeah I was really um
that was a big turning point for me that
doing that set cuz you use talk you were
like let's just talk about about that
you know it's not it you know i'm doing
i'm i'm getting ready to put up my show
finally and get a solo show her yes call
just does this show make me look fat
without my the title might be the
funniest thing but it's about my eating
disorder and that's like the kind of
stuff that I'm doing in the show is
really not comedy club stuff right of
it's funny but it's not a comedy club
show right and what I wanted to do what
I did for the Ferguson set as I took
whatever I could out of the show that
that lent him lent itself to a comedy
set yeah and then I i surrounded it with
with related material on yeah older an
image and body image and that kind of
stuff and it made it made it meant a lot
to me and I knew it was a good place to
do it because you know Craig was really
supportive and he's a recovering
alcoholic and you know and talk to me
about that when he was in treatment we
told right out of that on panel and he
said he would sit with an anorexic woman
at dinner and it was just it was all
very very interesting in a very
gratifying experience yeah it was it was
cool to watch and it's always weird to
me that he talks about being in recovery
because I to my knowledge it was there's
this anonymity that's supposed to happen
well but I don't know what I mean and I
don't it's none of my business so I try
not to give it my thinking
the anonymity is to not as I understand
it is to not reveal what you um speak
about or whom you with whom you speak oh
I thought it was I thought the anonymity
part of it was in case you dropped the
ball and started partying like a crazy
person than anybody coming to it and go
oh look what he hasn't work that is I
think that is that doesn't yeah and
whatever recovery doesn't work you might
as well just give up and eat a bullet
see how I'm feeling I don't even exactly
I don't even know if have been the right
to feel this way but I feel that by
showing your recovery that it gives
people hope and I mentioned we do it
yeah that outweighs the possibility of
someone dropping out right well I think
it also that people could argue with me
great I mean there are as many opinions
about that as you like you know so it's
all good and i don't i like that it that
he doesn't he's not super heavy handed
about it you know i mean everyone i know
he's not gorgeous i was izing or
anything right right everyone who I know
is sort of out about being in recovery
is is pretty gentle about it you know
Marin and he's out about it and Craig is
out about it and Hardwick is out about
being sober but not in recovery not in
any sort of he's doing it solo he's just
doing it with family oh okay and why
some people play it much closer to the
vest you know I mean it's my brother
Terry hasn't drank in like 40 years and
he he credits the Jesus all right that's
it that's another program right the
meanest Jesus though it's a lot of you
it's unfortunate I would like to turn a
punishing thing it's a punishing Jesus
and it's full of rage and that it's
really sad and it's a and I would call
it sad if I didn't have to talk to him
and then then it's exasperating and
irritating eight yes and it's like Cruz
I mean it's like somebody who like is
pushing yeah Shing pushing even even
insidiously atomic ones yes in fair
enough nice i like this inside with his
ships
but um no like what he said you know
anything I asked him a question about I
can't even remember what the question
was but he said well I'm sure we'll all
be praying about it excuse me Wow people
who don't tell me please don't make me
pray about something oh my thinking
irritates me is really you don't enjoy a
great deal of bossiness ok here's what
what I like to do is I like to talk
about people's dork nums go ahead i know
i'm no iring i weeded off almost
immediately i usually we get into it and
then I weed off ok it's uh there's so
much to talk about I like to break it up
yep and we haven't seen each other in a
I know I but not not in a substantial
way certainly I quote one of your jokes
all the time to both Maria Bamford and
my husband Andy ashcraft because you do
this thing about how sex as you get
older it's just a wrestling match of who
gets to be on the bottom remember that
bit me yeah I saw you do it at some
weird Tom handsome for wall yeah oh my
god I don't even remember them write it
down so stages it was funnies I'm dead
stead certain oh my Minneapolis you know
the neighborhood's next when you gettin
alters you don't remember your material
oh my god i get a great memory of it
I've quoted it with kilmartin on the
Jackie Laurie social i mean under this
is all you're absolutely certain I'm
absolutely certain because I was
watching you you had been in Minneapolis
for weeks I think with your fit with
your parents right and i'm with my
in-laws yeah or with your in-laws
because of Tom and then but uh well we
lived there for 16 months right you
lived there and so you were doing this
show for Tom Hanson like a la right so I
bet you don't remember a half an hour of
that material I'm sure I done yeah so
what the hell but do I know where it was
too oh god that was laughs sorry it was
at the house it was at a Holiday Inn
sure it was why wouldn't it be Tom
Hanson uh and God love you yeah and so
that guy should have had a bait shop
that's all I refer wanted you know Tommy
Hanson all he ever wanted in Minnesota
was a bait shot so many people so many
club owners shouldn't have been in
right well it is fun because I mean he
did the best he could and I think he's
not really doing it anymore but um he
genuinely I think Scott his brother got
him into it and then he's like well it's
a job I guess I'll just did the family
jizz it's a family business I could
still have dogs and you're like Tom just
open a bait shop and it live your life I
hope he's happy now because he had a lot
of he's remarried he really can you
remarried and then and he's living down
in Kentucky good so uh he is good hi
tough you're listening to the dark
forest aren't you it seems unlikely but
uh so I have two stories about you
before we talk about you we've gotta get
to that dark tomb we got to get to that
directive which is many years ago
probably five six years ago and I've
told this story out in various that's
not many it was a linear in the ten it
is it is and the door forest is 1000 she
probably sees yeah you know I've wanted
to do this for so long I can't believe
it's been 10 I know taking me 10 years
it was in you and this was in passing
and I have credited you this and I've
critically I remember this one this one
is harder cuz it makes you sound silly
ah but I mean it in the nicest way cuz
it makes me I like being silly excellent
I asked you to be on the show and I said
yes because you were talking about
knitting and you said think about
knitting is that knitting isn't dorky
it's cool I said that yeah and then we
got laughed and laughed and then you
laugh because you know everybody mitts
no no it's a cool thing and I was like
nope no it is not my friend actually
well it became it sort of become a lot
more popular um certainly uh in within
the visible people in Los Angeles and a
lot of the actors there was more in it i
doing it it was yeah but i really i have
you always eating i started knitting did
you learn back in the 1800s from your
great-grandmother i did i was aboard for
after i turned butter I did I can come
in hang up my apron and knit um what I
don't remember exactly um my mother
taught me how to knit I think but she
did was the never an avid knitter but
she wasn't an evidence it was not but
she knew from my grandmother okay
knitted
mostly crocheted I think but didn't it
and her she is that thing that holds
pots right you hang things from the top
of the ceiling and then and then you
stick a pot in it or you make like a
bracelet what are you what's washing is
with a hook it's a one-handed craft okay
knitting is two needles Oh intro with
crocheting I don't I might as fond of
crocheting as I am knitting um sometimes
I didn't know that you could do it with
one hand well crocheting is just one
it's one it's a crochet hook okay it's
about six inches long with a hook I mean
something you're just sort of weaving
the whatever loop through a loop through
loop through a loop but then there are
other ways that you wrap the yarn around
no good through different but I don't I
don't love the product the crochet
products as much as well of the knitted
product i think the knitted product
there's a lot more possibility that's
what i thought of yarn rights what I
think but ok Blue Crush no Coke I mean
hmm did you crochet with different oh
yeah why not i suppose and different see
and and and also with crocheting you can
do like kind of like like firmer cords
no girlfriend things but i'm not into
that a very short time i was in metin2
macrame oh my god oh that was Matt what
does when I listen to any craft you know
right um but that's good that's got a
sort of string attached to it I made a
plant hanger as everyone is okay so I'm
getting macrame and crochet mixed up
like what are you crochet with would you
be born wrong yarn you use yarn to
crochet and they are you making a
sweater or I had to make a sweater you
can make a hat you can make good
clothing but you but but with crucial
but macrame that's the thing that's
strong as you can with jute it's with
jute is the name of the Ju te ok and and
its editor you wouldn't want to put it
on your body it's not stronger the hair
shirt yeah yeah and and then you I mean
can do other things than everybody did
plant hangers it was right 70s it was
written Oh God OC ever do string hurt do
you ever do that have you ever seen the
nails with the wire art and then it's a
three-masted ship you're my favorite
members of the child I've seen it no I
never play my uncle hair
had a three-masted ship on black velvet
with nails and wire and it was string
art and it was a 0 is gorgeous
especially if you were nine yeah you a
nine you were like this is what isn't
gorgeous but you're not and you want to
get out of South Milwaukee Wisconsin and
you want you're like I want to get on
the open sea when will I meet pirates
and I think I would it be a cabin boy
anyway so but anyway so so my mother
taught me macrame and crochet but your
mother taught you knitting and I um and
I remember she gave me I started on her
number five needles which are kind of
small to start on in representing are
there different size needle oh yeah they
go all the way from I guess tiny one or
zero which yeah I don't like to work on
the tinier ones because it takes forever
to get a project does it make the stitch
smaller needles are small and you use it
much thinner yarn okay I'm very fine
like sock yarns invicta the okay a long
time to do and then the needles go all
the way up to if I don't know 17 okay so
I mean like English in 20 sings is your
whole like a horse's leg you know okay
sorry um did that skinny no I didn't
hear that that's good equipment huh but
um so I started making this cardigan it
was like an ivory ivory wool cardigan
and that was your first big project yeah
and I was interestingly i was working at
this horrible the department store for
this summer called Corvettes I think was
just in New York that's a great name
every day's a savings day ad for bed
where was for privates are shopping bag
is savings wow that is a somebody paid
someone to write that and and then I
remember I remembered it yeah it's on
Cape Cod there was a hey where you going
we're going to Thompson's clam bar cuz
that's where the tastiest clams are is
the seafood good the best by far and
then it went on like that for genuinely
like two more paragraphs Oh
so Corvettes where West Corvettes was it
a mouse others in New York's i was in
new york new york sir and there was
several and and core vetted the best
record department okay um that I mean
they had everything else was very bad oh
yeah but the albums were good for some
great record department and the best
prices and I get all my singles they
okay my albums if ya talking about one
you know I got 45 rpm sing sure which
which I which the standard price was 69
cents butts but when they are in sales
forty five senses and then did you get a
deal cuz you work there uh or didn't
know if it was already on sale we don't
remember if you got such a good deal on
records right you know I think there was
an exception in albums were only like
three dollars you know right but it was
it was also what the late 60s early 70s
I worked at Korvettes i was in college
so isn't it was the mid 70s mid
seventies early to mid 70s or early
early seven I don't remember getting 45s
and just being confused on how to play
them cuz the hole was too big you didn't
have an adapter we had an adapter but I
didn't it took me like I mean my buddy
showed me how to use anything in my
family everyone was just like you know
how to read don't you I'm the youngest
of six oh my god so I mean there's all
rights of this expectation is that you
must have learned how to put a 45 dealy
bobbin you've been observing people what
were what were here did you collected
45s you must have collect yeah and you
know what I'm so pissed off that I gave
my nephew my box of 40 50 any sold him
for rent on I'm sure he's okay I'm so
sick well you know what it would be more
junk for me exactly but um I still have
the very first album that um I think
that I either was bought or my sister's
gave to me and I it's actually framed
and hung up in my but i have three album
covers hung up in my bathroom now and a
couple that i got from goodwill and okay
one then i wrote my name on it so i see
my my cursive handwriting from when i
was eight years old right what was early
Beatles an early Beatles and early
Beatles oh it's called the early Beatles
is that a Beatles song a beatles album
photos album yeah and hmm is it like a
greatest hits um you know
I don't think it was I think it was a a
current because it must have their
current song maybe it was ironic maybe
they were the first hipsters oh maybe it
is maybe they knew it was they knew what
they had a future huh they must oh yeah
do you know anyone's just after this
nelly Jacob says knit even everything
was that I remember these number five
needles cuz i still have them because
there's a little tiny bend at the tip of
one of them now because I got it stuck
in my locker they even put my employee
locker at Korvettes but I could still
knit with it right now why are they
straight are these little I actually
it's interesting I've I've I now work on
circular needles always unless unless
it's not possible and I have to work on
double point needles that's a little bit
so we'd so there's a straight needle is
a circle circular needle a close or as I
horseshit vehicle that doesn't make any
signal it's it's what is to Shorter's
firm points okay and and then a flexible
wire sort of like that yeah so it's like
I you bendable it's a venda bowl and
what it's always like one big one that's
the end up when you go back you can
actually you can use a circular needle
if you're doing circular projects like
I've done I have this great poncho
actually I even wore when I was on Curb
Your Enthusiasm oh now that it's a great
um and that was done on circuit
uncirculated okay because there was so
much fabric that it was even done I may
have even had to add do it on to
circulating that once perhaps cuz it was
so big are the circular needles probably
end up being different lengths is that
right yes the cables see now now what I
have you know it's it in i've got i have
a set of interchangeable circular
needles that are really great oh well
and i feel like a socket set exactly
that's exactly what it is and i had one
set before the but they would they were
not great quality but this this these
are they came out with easily there so
you can't even it's so smooth between
you know will you screw on the end yeah
to a note seamless kind of yeah
you really you can barely feel where
it's good where it screwed in and also
the cables are incredibly flexible okay
they're they're terrific i love them in
the alcott i love the needle points too
because i bought a nickel-plated set but
then they came out with these wooden
sets yeah and oh my god I'm so in love
with him there's no practical reason
that I need to get them but right
everybody now and then I'll buy a set of
wooden tips because they're just so
luscious and a beautiful so wooden tips
I mean why are they point he just so you
can poke into the Indian blaming you
yeah they're not exactly like a pair not
sharp but there but they're only did
point is you can catch the yarn so you
can catch the loop okay oh I see ok and
so wooden ones versus copper ones versus
whatever it's just making sure that
they're smooth yay d want them to be
smooth and you also like the way the
needle the way the y aren't like the
nickel plated one are way more slippery
yeah so the yarn you can drop you can
it's easier to drop things drop stitches
Oh code on the wooden ones these
particularly would once was a particular
wood ones because I've worked on other
ones in there the yarn is a little bit
kind of catches on a little bit more
uh-huh these are really nice and smooth
but not as slick as the nickel one so
it's to me it's just the perfect kind of
consistency to keep a hold of the young
goodness okay well holds but lets it
move fair enough oh my god i love my
needles and I love my yard wait that's
the whole thing that this is it's like a
going into a yarn store where all the
yarn is like set up in categories by
colors and it's just so luscious and it
feels so good very tactile is always
wool it isn't always well now you can
you can work in it polyester I mean
there's that they have to have every
there isn't cotton yarn is there oh you
can make a cotton sweater jacket yeah so
why was there because none there's a
leather leather wool no no I don't
thinks you can't really knit with animal
fabric in fur thank you can I wonder if
this like I mean he's probably not done
any more it's done like a tiger pelt
that it be inappropriate first of all
and the Trump son
yeah I'm right but yeah it's it's all
different fabrics and they've at
contents and they've gotten so much
better in the manufacturing at you see I
mean there and there was are still
shitty yarns I mean some crappy yarns
but there are some beautiful acrylic
yarn z okay and there are some beautiful
superwash wolves that you can wash and
they come out great oh wait for baby
stuff and superwash oh ok so wool is
sort of the gold I mean now that was the
first one that I ever heard of cuz i had
an i did an episode about knitting with
diva zappa which I love divas abba but
it's all real organic man uh cuz she's
give us up okay so uh she was beautiful
it was so great but um she likes to use
this this yarn that is almost not there
like it's poufy it's super hard to get a
hold of the ship angora yeah kind of
baby it's it's a it's a it's there's
harder yarns to work with yeah I mean
like there are certainly yards that have
a very thin shaft but then it will have
some a lot a lot of like fibers coming
off coming off of it so that you can't
tell where you're actually grabbing be
like that yeah all right that's hard to
see ya who's what to see where the hole
is and with it you know where your grab
a chef's to the yarn right mass a shaft
please say today please say it again
shad thank you there you go that's what
you get folks Rangers live it up and
Kathy labman saying shaft and uh so um I
am curious though about how to knit so
you're given two so simple and also I've
been knitting you wrong for fraud not
wrong but kind of in a confusing manner
for a while on some of my stitches there
was an easier way my mother-in-law is an
excellent it if she said I think she's a
master knitter personally okay but um
she Swami an 81 times she goes what are
you doing exactly i showed her she goes
well actually I think it's and she's
English Minnesota she's a very should've
hind way of saying yeah actually well
there is this other way and if you do it
this way and it was like oh my god
you've opened the world really yeah it
really made
total sense because I even when I was
knitting before I realized well
something's wrong here why is this
stitch twisted here and what she
explained to me made it all clear
knitting is so simple it's a loop
through a loop okay so you make a loop
with one hand and then you'd well sugar
thing through thee that's crochet okay
what you do with knitting is you want to
do something called casting on you cast
on on one needle a number of stitches
that's gonna be your base your
foundation okay so when you cast on
that's when you start as a you start
let's try casting on 20 stitches okay
scarf yes something that's the eat
something simple or I don't wanna get
and you cast on and then what you do is
you start to build the fat German by
next row and they were basically there's
basically only one stitch okay but it's
looked at from two sides when you look
at it from one side it's called a knit
stitch and it's flat okay when you look
at it from the other side it's a purl
stitch and there are little bumps okay
but it's really the same stitch just
looked at from either side for yeah it's
like looking at one side of the page and
right side of the page guy but when
you're making a purl stitch you're gonna
hold the yarn that you're carrying that
you're working with to the front okay
and when you pull the loop through the
bloop is gonna fall to the front of the
work and that's where it makes that bump
okay and you do a knit stitch you're
holding you you on that you're working
with the back you pull the loop through
and leather phone but back so you're not
gonna see it's gonna be flat and smooth
interesting now when you're making a
scarf sometimes you don't want to make a
flat knit like that because it'll curl
so that's great that's why you want to
do Oh your alternative thing and some
kind of pattern that lies flat a little
bit better for a scarf now or you can
block it flat also that's another one
okay so a rib thing is what and blocking
is what okay a rib a rib stitch would be
classics rip stitches knit two purl two
oh okay Alton and what it does is I've
even heard that in it is very common and
it kind of the fabric kind of like gets
a little bit is sochi it's stretchy okay
it's how it ends up
interacting with each other and it's a
rib kind of feel to it cause like it
goes like kind of like a like like a
whale isn't Valley so okay but and then
you when you pull it apart you can eat
what you end up seeing when you're
looking at a ribbed fabric as you see
all the nits cuz that's kind of how it
okay then you pull it apart and then you
see the old girls are higher than they
oh that's awesome blocking is when you
finish something and you want to put it
into shape with steam okay so you're
kind of iron it or a pit well you don't
want to iron it right you can pin it I
don't know I don't have the space to
have all this stuff I would love one day
to have a crafts room but right you pin
it uh either on a blocking board or I
just use my ironing board okay can you
use these pins and and and two stretches
your you pin it to shape you don't
really want to stretch it but just kind
of like flat slightly stretch maybe to
shape and you measure where you want it
to be if it's supposed to be 12 x 12
square let's say you measure that and
then you'll you can put a fabric a flat
just kind of like old pillowcase over it
and then you like steam and you can
press lightly the pillowcase okay and
then that and then you let it dry and
then take it off it's it should be flat
and blocked okay so you have knitted a
pillowcase no no I haven't knitted a
pillow okay where did you get that I
don't know where I got no that I said
you put a like an old pillowcase over it
Oh to protect it very detected and okay
and it's just a fit it's like a you know
it's fine enough that you're not that
you can get through it but not burn
anything right I got it all right good
sure god you're grasping it I'm getting
it it's it's it's interesting like there
must be different levels of knitting
like someone who can just knit oh yeah
yeah well I've what a couple of things
with made but yeah I'd like I brought um
yeah if you bring it I can we can
describe it cuz I won't know what I'm
writing yet but it'll be perfect this is
a scarf thinner making
I my son-in-law and this is something
called you asked i have a friend a
facebook friend who's really she's a
she's a master knitter and she knits for
magazines this test pattern oh my god so
I said to her what would be a good
stitch to make first car French give me
a couple of ideas and this this is
called a mock rib stitch because not
exactly knit two purl two okay of like a
little off center and it comes out like
this and it's pretty I like super pretty
and you see how it recording in ish yeah
yeah and it's pretty funny actually
pearls the the tile or what see if this
is a little more more difficult to see
because it's not a crib yeah it's kind
of all it's not it's not as I in regular
rib you knit into a knit and your pearl
into a pearl in this one you kind of one
off okay you one off so that's why it's
not exactly a rib but I like it better
because it lies a little bit flatter
right and here's my question this top
the top of the scarf yes is that's the
cast on right that's the cast on ridge
and all you're doing there is what are
you attaching it to itself like are you
are you this was on the needle when I
started okay so the first so the needle
is six inches long or however long this
is right no it has to be you know a
needle has to be like twice as long yeah
but that I don't even know how long a
needleless i use lies i said i use here
the circular needle this is interesting
to everyone listen well she digs through
back no it is it well it's interesting
to be because the when you say cast on
what you're talking about is that you're
starting you starting starting a row of
stitches right and it stays on the
needle until you attached it to the next
thing you knit off of that and as you
knit it falls all go stop it goes down
and the fabric grows and grows okay it's
like the dead when you knit the first
row then that's the one that's on the
needle okay and the other one is now
often the cast is off the needle right
and gods attached but okay my needles
this is the wire needle or what
the water circular it's the cable that
right this is a circulant this is which
means it's more of a cable attached with
22 tips oh that's awesome yeah okay I'm
I mean these are the isn't this what
nice so what is nice it's a very pretty
word so where do you go to get stuff i
get these online at a place called Nick
pics I really love their k ni p yeah Kim
K nit nit p I cks okay and you know they
have very basic yarns and their prices
are great mmm you're not gonna get real
specialty yarns there but wasn't it
weird i am yarn on if garrett needle
kids too okay like buying urine online
this isn't kind of like buying clothes
online where you don't try it on or feel
well you can you can always buy sample
cards okay and see what they feel like
you can also call them and and these
people know what they're talking about
they'll talk you through it and they can
say this is very soft it's kind of soft
it has a little bit of a nubby texture
to it or what or what ever you know the
different knitting words and that you
know what they mean because you've been
doing it forever okay so I mean but but
the reason I like them is that it's
really affordable and they have good
quality yarns right um now this is this
is the kind of project that i can do
like i used to knit when i was writing
on shows yeah hit in the writers room
maybe go to and my friend jack told me
he started knitting and a lot of people
like loved what it was very soothing to
watch yes vet and it's also it's so i
love doing it while i'm doing something
else cuz I'm what it's it feels like
multitasking but is it not as it just
sorta this is such an easy like once you
start doing it I barely have to think
about it okay um as opposed to data
entry which is also repetitive but not
as soothing can't do that level but then
i'm working on this other project and
you can do this while you're watching TV
well sure movie on TV you know yeah I've
seen I've seen people do it just sort of
a coffee shops and stuff we're just
hanging out in there there's time run
like the book club we'll sit around
their friends this is the kind of
project that I like to always have going
something simple that's like a TV movie
proj oh it's kind of a background
project exactly cuz then then there's
other projects that are like destination
why kind of holiday this music kind of
project sure but this what I'm making
for my best friend and I haven't gone I
haven't done this in over a month so i
have to get oh you're gonna this is
gonna blow your mind here all right i am
making felted the I'm they're gonna be
felt it which means oh they're stuck on
the Shh well they're not it it's just
another bag the other bag has it kind of
a thing here alright um knitters of the
first people who ever had hippie bags
like for groceries oh yes because you're
like and and it doesn't ever because
they're all open kind of grocery bags
now that Ryan does it do you have to put
it in the bags carefully and take it out
of the bag carefully to make sure
they're not ripping it a buzz some
people use needle tips like when they're
putting their projects back in bags okay
to make sure they thought to keep them
together to make sure the yarn doesn't
slide off the needle in true but I
needle say I'm too impatient mm-hmm to
do that so but this what I'm making is
I'm doing this on double double point
needles because it's so it's very
confused double point and so a single
point anything's don't have the tapered
ends on both sides is what you're saying
no they don't they have it they have a
flat closure at the end right like a
kind of like a thumbtack oh you know
anything what's it up oh just to stop
the flow of yarn could be a large be
dependent on of needles yeah yeah but um
these are pointed at both ends and
usually like socks you can make socks
there's certain ways you can make socks
with two circular needles oh uh but um
these are pointed at both ends and their
bed i would say about eight inches long
right and the reason that you use these
is because the the product that you're
making in this case a knittin a mitten
and it's done in a circular fashion
is that it's too small of a circle you
know to do with straight needles or with
Cirque even with circular needles and it
just because would work because it's so
tiny it's tiny so you so you need two
needles or you need you and more you
need four of these you need for new
usually and sometimes five with both
ends yeah and you do you knit it in a
circle okay but and I don't even you
know what I hate when I stop a project
that have to like really think when I go
you're really is like with way the [ __ ]
am well yeah but and then you do it in a
circle but you do it like the circle is
three needles or four needles ok and you
evenly distribute these stitches that
you're working on and one needle is free
and that's the one you work on to each
time you go and what you're doing is
you're adding stitches to each of those
three other needles is that what your
dad and you just knitting off of them
you're okay it's it's it's like I don't
want to knit because I don't know if
from I'm worried yeah you let's say I'm
knitting right here yeah for this then
all these stitches will end up on this
needle and then this will be my free
needle okay oh cuz you'll pull it out
right I get it okay so you'll knit on
the free needle uh and then you'll
you'll move from one of the three
needles to the next of the three needles
cuz I you'll get a new free needle exam
you're done with a rose yeah and you'll
go to the next one and that will create
the circle yes that'll create sort of
the wristband of emitting or whatever
know what I just realized while I'm
talking to you what I'm not afraid of
trying anything new knitting I am not
afraid of it yeah which is why I've done
so many different things but in life I
am so afraid oh we're and maybe this is
the way I find to conquer my fear yeah
why not maybe I had so I am sweaty
venturous with your adventurous with
with now are you adventurous with
knitting because it's just knitting or
is it like because you can always undo
right don't you have to take apart yes
and that's got to be a pain in the neck
but sometimes it is but I would read I
mean like there's a mistaken in
my son in law's scarf yeah I thought I
don't wanna i want to eat you know it's
such a beautiful divas emphasis why she
says that's just part of the the beauty
of it exactly i remember when as a kid
going to the UN on a field trip in New
York and you know cuz that's where I
grew up and we had great field trips
because was New York yeah that amazing
and so we went to the UN and um there's
a key there was a huge tapestry hanging
from a wall enormous tapestry and to me
this was so actually like so what's the
word I'm looking for presumptuous of
took concept that the guide said to the
children that and there was it there was
a mistake intentionally put into this
tapestry show that only God is oh that's
right right right I'm thinking what huh
and then yes retailers do that years
later effect you know as an adult one
day I thought well it was gonna be a
mistake in there anyway right you
shouldn't have to make You mr. he's
perfect right then you know yeah and you
don't necessarily have you it is a
little bit though I'm right to think
that you have to create because you're a
perfect being well I better make this
mistake intentionally because I want to
make sure that right then I'm making a
mistake anyway the mistakes gonna be
there and the other thing is is it's a
great rationalization for not fixing a
mistake mm-hmm right now tempest trees
what the hell are tapestries are those
wovens the nose giant air giant things
that wouldn't with with petrunka Jonah
yeah don't have to do I don't know know
what my sister-in-law has has or had a
little Matt her house Oh interested that
have you ever seen the spinning of yarn
have you ever done I've never witnessed
it but when I was in China adopting my
daughter we went to the fabric they had
like great fabric Mart and I ground and
I still haven't haven't used it but I
bought some cashmere yarn on us on a
spool oh wow and um I love knitting with
cashmere but it's very expensive so you
so you need to end and choose very quick
very specifically what you're gonna make
and make sure yeah
and I still haven't been able to much i
have so i mean i got i just got rid of a
lot of yarn that I thought I had so much
money's worth of yarn I don't know what
I was gonna make with it so I just had
it because I bet you wouldn't when you
start looking at yarn you're just like
oh the possibilities are endless and
then all of a sudden you have stacks of
yarn and like I don't know what to do
with this yes my mother-in-law has an
addict full of yarn she's got a dick for
yes um I have books like that and I just
keep buying books and I'm like I'm never
gonna read you when you read do you buy
books who take them from the life i buy
them I used to do the library and then I
travel so much that I'm just wandering
through too many bookstores in too many
town and you read a lot I read a fair
amount but I also such a bad book reader
I i have so many different things that
i'm reading yeah it takes me so long to
get through a book and it's frustrating
but isn't it great to start many books
at once some people like to read one
book at a time I'd like to have like
five things going at it one I have five
books going it's I have a nonfiction
book that I'm reading by eric bogosian i
have a couple of rereads that i bring on
the road with me like what just usually
romance novels or science fiction novels
that are just soothing like if I'm if
I'm twitchy eye and and then I also have
usually a book or two on kindle I like
using that I'm uh yeah it's harder it's
usually a reread on kindle as well i'm
rewriting some books from when I was a
kid that I the it's a it's a world it's
a civil war series written by a guy
named Altschuler it's a boys it's a boy
series it's four books are set from one
cousin who fought for the south and for
Brooks except from the other cousin who
fought for the north sounds cool yes
have you heard him in the early 1900s oh
you know what I just thought what boy
you know Stephanie story no um Stephanie
story is um you should know um ism God
was Mike and all fees wife oh wow Mike
and I by Mike Gaddafi yet and very funny
guy yeah he is a very funny guy and she
um just wrote her first novel and it's
getting amazing reviews Stephanie story
yes st 0 re y sto are you want and it
called oil and marble and I am suck I
mean one of the reasons I bought is to
support a friend right the other reason
is that's the only time I'm been buying
books a lot recently is to support
people i know right and you're like I
you pray to God that they're good
because it's like it's sort of like
watching someone's TV show or listening
to their album you're like please be
funny please be smart please be good and
it's always great so oil and marble is
it and it sister no it's his it's like
like tional hit his historical fiction
which I love oh if I aneurysm stay a
virgin yeah Leonardo da Vinci and
Michelangelo at the same time oil da
Vinci marble be Michelangelo okay yeah
but actually create your entirely oath
of them actually the only goal do media
I think so yes um I have not started it
yet because I I have like really I have
a pile of books that are at least a foot
high right on fiction fiction just very
self improvement do you do uh books on
tape you ever do audible uh you know
what I like it a lot but I I don't have
time jack gavel these podcasts and I
idle recently punk as you are Rangers
keep listening to this podcast but I
don't listen to any podcasts I listen to
books on tape and so and I also relisten
the books on tape like right now I'm
relisting for the hundredth time
assassination vacation by serve all I
don't even know what that is it's a it's
about the assassinations of McKinley
Lincoln and Garfield oh my god and it's
very funny because it's written by serve
all I don't even she reads it oh she
said and she's impure lady and you say
spell her last night vo w.e.l.l Sarah
with an H she was on the daily show a
lot oh I'm sorry look at that look at
the discovery it's a beautiful discovery
time ever oh yes so um I have two books
on tape it my stepson bought me and I
haven't listened to them right well
there it's it's hard cuz you gotta be
either you got to put them on your ipod
and fly around a lot right or you gotta
drive alarm a lot yeah and when I Drive
I'm generally listening to pastor brock
oh and politics vodkas
well I don't have you know talk to me I
have an older car so I don't have like a
great podcast set up in my car right I
can listen to my blue through my
bluetooth right it's a tinny sound oh
but like I don't know if there's any way
to set up my car so I can listen through
my speakers yes have an old car right
you'd have to one year with my 2003
toyota corolla andy got me for my
birthday yes a new radio that had a sync
thing so so i can do that yeah him at
2,400 cord there you go go over to frys
okay and and they'll hook you up frys
electronics and lush and for I don't
know what it was probably two or
discovery two or three hundred dollars
and they will set it up for you and then
your phone can work through your
speakers that would be great and I'm get
rid of this that's stupid Bluetooth
fingers sometimes work and sometimes
doesn't and right this is it was the
same testaments synz is what i recommend
ok it's what they're in all right words
yeah I think that's the the software
brand love to buy a new car and I just
can't afford it now well fair enough and
so does it run to you what do you like a
new car I do I would like to get first
of all I would like to get a car that's
under warranty Oh interest to worry but
repairs now because okay no 2004 they'll
repairs are coming yes how many miles on
that Accord um 120,000 it's that's not
bad no it's not i mean i don't drive a
live it's the most i've ever had on
mileage and the honda accord that's a
that's a hell of a road car my friend
it's a good car if you want to go back
to the road yes that's good but that
should that the you wanna be driving
yeah although the other night I did a
gig in Santa Barbara and I with glory
kilmartin yeah I was driving home and I
I'm so glad i usually stay for the whole
show but I I had the option of leaving
early right and I and I conduct an hour
and a half and I took it and let me tell
you that last 45 minutes thank God my
friend Bev Mickens called me and Finn
soldier call me you know I'll be on the
road so she calls me at like 1030 or so
I don't care what your wife and I was
like oh thank god because blazer cook
for 15 minutes I was fighting it and
fighting it and it was so hard and I
should talk to me the whole way home
when I pulled into my carport I was
talking to her and I
for a few times I i said what i did i
say it'll 904 what I say 950 and there
were a few times and Bev is so good she
goes yeah 950 I mean she's she was
trying to be supportive it was always
like very affirming and I did it a few
times 8 and I said wait a second what I
would I just say hissing what I cry got
a gift well you're terrifying yeah
that's a terrifying story of Kathy lemon
driving and it was very scary at one
point I thought I wanted to pull over
but I want to get home so badly and yeah
for those listening I these are poor
driving decision right don't do it Maya
my iPad fits right over my steering
wheel oh how does that happen well you
just broke because I have the case holds
underneath the hood of where the
speedometer is and so it can just be
there and so I can put you know ways
honor mapquest oh oh oh I see what
you're saying yes but do I and I do but
if I also looking at Twitter a little
bit at stoplights I it isn't okay I'm
doing things that are did I have a
twelve-year-old daughter and I really
have to like I have essence good model
yeah you're supposed to be a we're ball
supposed to be a mocha I said you don't
know I'm please remind me just chuckle
mom and I thank you thank you Anna and
then when she's not in the car I get
sloppy yeah and it's stupid it's yeah
it's to there's no I don't understand
accident Oh have you while I was I this
is so I've got her a ticket horribly
embarrassed okay playing a game oh you
were playing a game yes I heels a game
of driving is a game I but I and I am
sympathetic I am so embarrassed it's a
little bit alluring right what were you
doing great I can't even remember it was
with these dots that it was a horrible
it was horrible right because driving
and listening to a podcast is not enough
well I think we also an even podcast
then right but radio it was on my mom
that tells you hello Wow Palm Pilot
ladies and gentlemen back to what is you
you got a ticket to and why i don't know
i was on my an ipad on the five and it
was almost standstill or it was
standstill it could have been standstill
i'll do something standstill yeah and
whatever it was but the cop steam coming
out of his ears he was so mad at me
he just he was like this is worse than
your phone your iPad is worse than your
phone and I was like all right I mean I
didn't have I mean had you know whenever
someone's out well know whenever any I'm
a middle-aged white lady so not that
scared and when everyone I get scared
with someone in monish is me but I
always I'm an enormous mean it I'm
always polite when anyone's armed yeah
I'm always i'm doing i'm always and even
when i got my duis and stuff um i do you
want to to do ice but the capsule are
always super polite many years ago in
minnesota one in minnesota one here in
Los Angeles yeah yeah I have friends
we've gotten them in several different
states that's the way to go by the way
do you ever drink it in Drive I do not I
do not good and not at this time
hopefully not too lets you drink anymore
I don't drink anymore oh so there you go
yeah I didn't grad to wrap it up and so
rapid us my brave up my favorite line in
defending your life Oh am Albert Brooks
is going on and on and on and you know
Rip Torn is his yeah his lawyer and and
he's going on and digging himself into a
hole explaining in Brooklyn goes Rip
Torn makes all movies better and
defending your life is one of the
greatest movies on worldwide it's a
brilliant concept with a brilliant
execution fantastic cast great jokes you
could not be weak a dork out very easily
on cuz i love defending your life and i
love mother oh i love mother and a lot
of people did not like it a lot of
people would my friend jim was her
friend of the show Jim mooster has he
says there's two different kinds of
Albert Brooks fans there's essentially
the people who like friends and the
people who like Seinfeld and I'm like
hey yeah gasps and he's like do you like
remember the drive the one where um his
early stuff like Albert Brooks is early
stuff oh you mean like rough lost lost
in America America brought something
real modern romance lot of romance and I
love modern romance those to make me
uncomfortable they do yeah I love
defending your life and mother more than
the early stuff in my
romance when he's you know he works in
he's producing this film yeah he's
working on the Foley you know sound
effects on the film and and George
Kennedy is actually in this scene and
it's it's this space some it's this it's
this us there on a spaceship or
something and they're running down a
hallway and then you want to sound
different Foley sounds and one of them
sounds like it sort of sounds horrible
hilarious scene yeah see these two Union
guys doing like Foley guys doing what
he's asking them to do yeah and they
finally do it and he smells like he's
like so excited what are you thinking
one guy goes I think you saved the
picture yeah see that's my favorite
thing about about Albert Brooks is that
you know he's for me he's a more
accessible Woody Allen and I like
because he is he feels more human he
feels more faceted well I think he's a
less intellectual um I don't know I
think he's smart but he's less
intellectual I think that Woody Allen's
a little bit of a poser with the
intellectual you think so I do but
that's um I loved Annie Hall yeah but I
haven't watched anything since he
married his dad died I mean it's been
very hot and her sis tit was the last
one I saw Hannah it was brilliant it's a
great a great movie brilliant and it's
it's absolutely I I wrote him I saw it
four times in the theater in a row a
letter and he wrote me back and it's
weds night I wall I that I was you know
cuz I'm from three girls three daughters
yeah and the chemistry and the Isle of
roadway Danny Rose oh I love oh my god I
love Burlington and my friend you I'm
friends with Jack Rollins daughters and
new sheqel check Rollins no no I don't
know part of show business that doesn't
know anybody who's Jack were all Jack
Rollins was very famous comedy producer
oh they're just died this past year at a
hundred okay and not a career cut
tragically short Nichols and May well
started Harry Belafonte Tony Bennett
anyone had started together as a comedy
with nickels
may discovered Woody Allen Wow have it
Robert Klein um then a bunch some of the
elders jolla Jack Rollins yeah and he's
he's in the the opening scene in the
deli with Sandy baron yeah and all those
older comics yeah court jack is in there
and he's got these really baggy eyes and
he's just smiling and he's not saying
anything but he's just hanging out there
yeah them and it's just a fantastic
scene that's where all telling their
stories Nick and Jess Andy Barron goes
ok now you Finn you'll finish then
you'll finish this is jess store
Broadway Danny Rose story of all time
and then it morphs into your right ok I
mean there there is what I like about
Albert Brooks is is that is it's a more
of a 360 view of humanity and it's uh
and with Woody Allen it is more its
surgical it feels like the the it'sit's
much sharper and much maybe intellectual
is the word but it's very anachronistic
Woody Allen he's from another time and
he adores another time yeah he adores
the authorities in the 40 yeah the doors
that so there's a lot of that texture in
his films Albert Brooks is more modern
he is more modern yeah he's reads
William brace today yes it feels and it
feels more accessible but it feels just
as smart oh but it isn't quite as I
don't think it's I don't think it's uh
plane to the bottom of the room but oh
my god any chance neither one no but um
I mean I and I what I invert but it has
that vibe Woody Allen has that 20s 30s
40s five it's you know he's he's very
specific in his in his choices that some
people might not know his his references
all there are a lot of people of you all
might not know and those some of them
that I don't know right but um but I
just happened to love his sensibility I
generally do and I remember seeing
sleeper when it came out with your
parents and I was you know with an
adolescent brain why he in fact I set
separately from them I said I me on the
other side of the aisle from them and it
was it was really funny but I developed
a greater
appreciation for it as an adult there
are just things that make me laugh so
hard right in sleeper yeah and also it's
so funny is the is how ridiculous we
thought the amount sold was on mcdonald
sign we thought oh that's such a big
number it 11 young and it came to pass
and so it came to pass yeah sure it's uh
yeah that is that is crazy like the top
movies like right well and and we r or l
must yeah we're close we're close to an
hour movies another time we'll do yeah
you got to come back heavy line because
here's do you read or is there any
resources like if people want to learn
how to knit and stuff and they don't
have your mother-in-law is a manner and
your mother to teach you we ever know
you know what's so great that they have
now yet they didn't have is uh these
video tutorials okay what's with your
great and you can go on on a resource
fair so you can go to Nick nitpicks calm
you may have some of their own tutorials
which I think are free yeah um but there
are there's gotta be a youtube Rep
there's the old tons of YouTube's you to
rabbit hole but my dog absolutely yeah
and then this is a this other place that
I like called craftsy.com with an s why
crafty like the word craft yeah well
then ask you to see not in the comedy
way of AK cuz they're not trying to be
hilarious oh god you could only see my
facial expression now but um daddy 11
does not approve no craftsy.com and they
have tons of classes you pay for them
but some of them are not expensive and
where I was going about having those
classes if they're downloaded and also
you keep them you keep them and then you
can go to them at any point as a
reference but truth truth is you can
also do the same thing with YouTube you
can save if you and what a good what a
thing about learning to knit is
everybody forgets had a cast on over and
over and over again at the Vietnam
because you do it once then you do your
project then you can start your project
the second project is like oh my god how
do I cast done right so you have to
refer to it a lot so do you have these
videos you don't go to meetings or the
way I had to
in the dark age right do you have any
books I mean why have so many books and
I and I had saved so many magazines and
I had to just let them do some purging
and I also used to subscribe to vogue
knitting and I finally let that go
because I wasn't doing anything any of
their stuff it's fun to look at though I
can I can dork out on living patterns oh
there's gorgeous stuff like waiting Oh
what's the hardest thing to knit like is
it is it a mitten is it a sweater a
little it's T it's a little um awkward
like the the masa Nations you have to go
through to get like a new round to doing
and I'm doing what is that is that a
mitten it's gonna be a mitten it's and
it's felted so that's why it's so huge
what's rounded what oh well this will
shrink in the see how business ditches
yeah this will shrink and become like a
tight fabric we almost don't even see
the stitches any more like felt oh I see
very cool because here's what I was
thinking um I bought the most expensive
mittens in the world in Madison
Wisconsin cuz I had lost my hat and
mitten so I decided to spend too much
money an embarrassing amount of money
instead of walking down the block on
State Street to ragstock and buying
normal style I bought essentially
repurpose sweaters that had been met
together and then lined with something
felt or something and if there's
gorgeous but they were their crafts
right and they were handmade of course
and that's and they deserve to be every
dime of the fifty dollars i spent on
mittens that i will one day lose you
know what you need to do let go to go to
Barney's yeah and look at the prices
there and and then you'll realize what a
bargain you got and plus at least it was
a lady or a person who made it instead
of just kidding Jackie it felt like a
lot of money I answer but it's not a lot
of money especially for amount of work
that everybody's done I know and the
lady and whoever made him I assume who
knows it could have been a felon but uh
oh yeah this is very famous knitter and
I could forget his name very famous
master knitter in Minnesota who is a guy
who who gives the Masters how do you
know if your mouth exactly maybe the
magazines and stuff or there's just
I mean there there are all sorts of like
clubs and organizations probably you
know what I've never gone to it I really
want to go to is the vogue knitting like
festival or something like a comic
adventure yeah oh wow I bet the
convention I would love to go to it and
she go to that it was in LA once and I
missed it oh there's no its track then
I'd have to travel to another city and
saint hotel and then i would get this
daughter and handler you're gonna four
days and you know right well you could
go for three i have to have anyone i do
that right you'd have to have money cuz
you did you wanna buy stuff you want to
buy stuff but imagine three days when
you're just sitting around talking to
people who only want to talk a minute
but you know here's the anxiety in that
yeah is being there and trying to allow
myself to get lost in that and then
having to go back to my life and get
caught up with everything else I mean
that's insane that's future that's
living in the future yeah that's right
that is another's a future that has not
happened that's right but let me tell
you something about the comic up comic
book conventions and anime all yours
good with convention I don't I go to any
number of conventions and you can sit
around with somebody and they will go
down a rabbit hole of luft Marvel and DC
and and it is amazing and then you leave
and you do you feel a real loss cuz
you're like I connected I know with
other people who love something as much
as I know so I would recommend to you I
really you wouldn't lose it you wouldn't
lose anything for it you would gain
something I should I should I mean what
would I have is one saving up some money
to spare I should do that um and also
you know when you get that feeling oh I
want this cup ah subway MTA yeah I got
why is yeah we got six of them for when
it's a pint glass I would like that all
right well I might have to York yeah um
I um when you're when you're connecting
with people on a man intense level about
something that you have such passion
about right for me I feel like no
inkling of depression of worried right
of anxiety because everything is all
about love you're just now connected
yeah and it's it's said connection is
incredibly powerful it really makes
everything feel okay mm-hm you know
mm-hm and if you if I could find if I
could try to find that each day in my
life obviously I'm not gonna find it all
day but I have pockets of that love you
each day I'd be a much happier and
healthier person I really what yeah but
there's there's no reason not to sort of
did I mean that I think that's why there
are a threat you know they're there are
Facebook groups and yes there are things
like that where you can just you can go
down that rabbit hole online verbally so
tonight I came home I did a really
wonderful show called break or broken
shell miracle does it it's a
storytelling show okay at the garage and
culver city okay and it I loved the show
I had only seen it once i went down to
see it just cuz i wanted to get out and
do something and yeah see some friends
work and it was wonderful and it's all
about heartbreak and no I'm just broken
your heart and it's there it can be very
funny it can be very poignant it don't
have to be a better romance could be bad
that's tons of things that break your
heart your life people lose a dog in
there they're out of their minds yeah
and and you owe you find out that
something you believed wasn't true feet
of clay feet of clay feel that's what it
is is that what that means well that's
that means it's like so someone that you
believed in yeah this human or something
that you believed right is fun as in a
myth or Santa Claus or whatever
something like her yeah you find out
that it's you go to the your visit
something in holly with the set of a
show that you loved and it's all right
fake write anything anything anyway it
so is this a very broad amount that you
can go through but I so I did this last
night and I I drove home and um Hetty I
want to eat something and I started
everybody else was asleep and and
everybody I mean been beating my husband
wife my daughter the lack of a moist
Liron
and so I turned on I had been watching
Bessie with Queen Latifah because I've
never seen it and I was in the middle of
it and I got so so involved in it that I
stayed up way too late and sure imaged
it it's so wonderful what if you can
catch it it's so one TV show movie it's
an HBO Oh kevie and I'm so beautifully
done and so what so beautifully
performed and she is such an amazing
talent I remember working with her years
ago Queen Latifah yeah well that's cool
oh my god she's such an amazing there
was a romantic comedy I just saw a
Christmas with her that I can't remember
the name of but it's a is there's not
absolutely nothing wrong with that movie
it's about she thinks she has a terminal
disease and people are yelling at their
iPods because they remember it but she
doesn't but she decides to live her life
to the fullest and take all of her
savings and go to the most expensive
like one percent kind of screen short
and Gerard Depardieu is in it and it is
very it's very life affirming and very
beautiful you would like it it's what's
sweet um I probably would and there's
another movie that I'd seen her and with
the Holly Hunter um one which I loved
called lip living living large or
something I have to a guy have to look
it up it's about a woman whose husband
leaves her and then she meets Queen
Latifah who's a singer in this place and
brownie and it's wonderful wonderful uh
it's a quizlet a prosaic and she's very
talented her voice is incredible whereas
a wonderful actress right so hey if you
guys have worked for Queen Latifah out
there we'd like to recommend that that's
right so Bessie so I stayed up too late
which is why I'm a little tired this
morning but this right very invigoration
oh where are you gonna be here and
you've also doing stand-up and shows
here in Los Angeles right because I'm
the most of my energies is going towards
memorizing and getting my show up at the
last stages of memorization and we're
when's your show going up here here in
Los Angeles as well learn so long i'm
gonna start workshopping it here so i'm
not going to tell anybody where it's
going to be quite yet so people follow
at Kathy labman on Twitter and then
you'll find out when
it's when it's also yes or Cathy lab and
calm I first I haven't I have a website
[ __ ] which is kind of like a
placeholder at this point but once my
show is up I'll be putting a lot more
things on a position make me look fat
com does this show make me look fat gum
very funny um um yeah that's about it
that's about it fine Kathy lemon and
watch your thoughts out of her Joe Cole
yeah exactly exactly and I'm loving
doing some local shows excellent thank
you so much for coming on the door
course I'm all right you guys you know
the rules take care of each other out
there I had my hat my hat they're
dancing around my hat I hat my hat my
hat well what do you think of that if it
looks like a Mexican Hat dance and it
sounds like a Mexican Hat dance it's
most likely a Mexican ackin so take off
your head and let stand yay oh my god we
why don't we just call that as the end
of the show